die AFD kommt aus dem Feiern gar nicht
mehr raus jetzt hat die Partei auch den
ersten oberbürgermeisterposten ergattert
in Pirna in Sachsen die Stadt ist ja
seit langem AFD
Hochburg es gibt mittlerweile mehrere
Bürgermeister der AFD einen Landrat
sogar in Thüringen und in ganz
Ostdeutschland liegt die Partei in
Umfragen aktuell bei über 30%. ja und da
steigt natürlich die Nervosität sind die
eigentlich noch zu stoppen und wenn ja
wie der CDU Bundestagsabgeordnete Marco
wanderwitz der würde die AFD am liebsten
ganz verbieten lassen der sucht gerade
Mitstreiter in allen Parteien für einen
solchen Verbotsantrag beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht und ich tue das
weil ich die AFD für eine rechtsradikale
Partei und eine große Gefahr für unsere
Demokratie halte es ist 11 Uhr und wenn
wir diskutieren bis es 51ch 12 Uhr ist
dann machen die der Demokratie das Licht
aus nein nicht verbieten hält der
Bundesjustizminister dagegen das sei aus
Mangel an Beweisen ein aussichtsloses
Verfahren so Mar Busch von der FDP und
damit ein propagandafest für die AFD und
die AFD Chefs rüsten verbal schon mal
auf dafür stasie ist das stasie Methoden
sind das korrekt übelste stasieethoden
das ist der Moment wo sich selbst harpe
Kerkeling einschaltet und der würde so
ein AFD Verbot richtig gut heißen
exbundespräsident Gauk wiederum lehnt
die Debatte rundwg ab Joachim Gauk sagte
in diesem Zeitungsinterview nicht alles
was wir nicht mögen können wir verbieten
tja was denkt ihr denn so ganz spontan
die AFD verbieten geht das so einfach
und werd ihr dafür oder dagegen schreibt
uns gerne in die Kommentare und dann
gucken wir uns mal zusammen ein bisschen
genauer an wohin uns diese
Verbotsdebatte wirklich führen
[Applaus]
könnte mein Name ist Christiane hübscher
und ich berichte aus dem ZDF
Hauptstadtstudio heraus unter anderem
über die AFD und die Debatte über ihr
Verbot ist kürzlich erstmals ziemlich
eskaliert als nämlich eine
Aktivistengruppe namens Zentrum für
politische Schönheit vor Kanzleramt
diese Installation hier aufstellen ließ
Alice Weidel Tino kropaller und Björn
höcke hinter Gittern dazu die
unmissverständliche Aufforderung AFD
Verbot die Aktivisten haben dazu auch
ein Video veröffentlicht produziert mit
Hilfe von künstlicher Intelligenz indem
sie den fakekanzler sagen ließen die
Bundesregierung arbeite bereits aktiv an
einem solchen Verbot dieses Video zeigen
wir euch bewusst nicht weil es nämlich
reine Fiktion ist in Wahrheit hält der
Kanzler so gar nichts von der Idee hört
mal ich bin kein Freund von einem Verbot
der AFD ich bin überzeugt die bürgerinen
und Bürger werden dafür Sorge tragen
dass die Bedeutung dieser Partei wieder
abnimmt sagt der Kanzler dem Spiegel ja
Herr Scholz das hat nur schon die
letzten 5 Jahre überhaupt nicht
funktioniert das hoffen darauf dass
diese Partei sich schon von selbst
entlarft entzaubert wie es immer wieder
so schön heißt dass die Leute schon
merken werden wenn sie da gewählt haben
ich finde ein politisches Versagen dass
auch Marco der Witz eingestehen muss in
der Tat sind wir so gesehen nicht
besonders erfolgreich gewesen die AFD
politisch zu schlagen denn einerseits
radikalisiert sie sich immer weiter und
auf der anderen Seite kennt sie nur den
Weg nach oben mit Umfragen und Wahlen
ich höre da erstmal eine ganz große
Hilflosigkeit heraus ihr auch die
Politik kommt der AFD anders nicht mehr
bei als mit einem
[Musik]
Verbotsantrag wanderwitz ist der der im
Bundestag am lautesten für das Verbot
trommelt der CDA aus Sachsen hat sich
schon als ostbeauftragte unter Merkel an
der AFD abgearbeitet und war schon
damals nicht unumstritten ausgerechnet
er hat dann seinen Wahlkreis bei der
letzten Bundestagswahl verloren an die
AFD Marco wanderwitz und afdchef Tino
kopalla kennen sich noch aus der Jungen
Union in der eben auch kopalla Anfang
der 90er Mal war das alles nur mal zur
Einordnung für euch wanderwitz braucht
nun 36 Mitstreiter um ein
Verbotsverfahren beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht zu beantragen
er hat sie theoretisch zusammen sagt er
mir im Interview angeblich sind
Mitglieder aus allen Fraktionen darunter
warum will er die AFD verbieten lassen
frage ich ihn ich glaube das wäre eine
große Atempause für die Demokratie weil
derzeit tausende von Rechtsradikalen den
ganzen Tag in der analogen und der
digitalen Welt ihr rechtsradikal sein
leider erfolgreich verbreiten und damit
wir über wiederhaup wieder eine Chance
haben Menschen zu erreichen für die
Demokratie die derzeit AFD wählen glaube
ich bedarf es genau dieses ihr könnt
euch sicher sein dass die AFD das
Treiben von Marco wanderwitz genau
beobachtet nach außenhin tut man
natürlich so als wäre die ganze Debatte
vollkommen absurd schaut hier wie Tino
kropalla und Alis Weidel auf meine Frage
reagieren wie ernst müssen sie so eine
Debatte so eine Verbotsdebatte als
parteinhmen her wanderwiitz glaubt doch
nicht im Ernst dass ein Antrag im
Bundestag mit den Mehrheiten im
Bundestag zu einem Verbot der AFD führen
können das ist
undemokratischer Diskurs absolut
undemokratisch und auch rechtswidrig was
dieser Mann macht er spricht ja sogar
davon dass dann die Mitarbeiter
entlassen werden müssten sofort dass die
Mandatsträger sofort aus den Parlamenten
verschwinden müssten das erinnert an
düstere und dunkelste Zeiten die wir in
der Geschichte schon mal hatten Stasi
ist das aber wie wahrscheinlich ist es
denn dass so ein Verbotsverfahren
tatsächlich kommen würde dafür müssen
wir mal kurz in die Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik
[Musik]
einsteigen tatsächlich sehen viele
Juristen beim Blick zurück wenig Sch für
ein erfolgreiches AFD Verbotsverfahren
wir haben erst drei Fälle in denen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht überhaupt
entschieden hat deswegen ist jede
Vorhersage mit Skepsis zu genießen ich
persönlich bin aber tatsächlich eher
vorsichtig was die Erfolgsaussichten
eines solchen Verfahrens gegen die AFD
angehen würde ja die drei Fälle die Frau
Schönenberger da anspricht das sind
diese zwei Parteien sind in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik schon
verboten worden das war zum einen die
sozialistische Reichspartei das war eine
NS nachfolg Partei und 1956 dann die KPD
das war eine kommunistische Partei dann
gab es das geschiterte NPD Verfahren
eigentlich waren es ja sogar zwei das
erste ist daran geschitert dass die NPD
von fauluten des Verfassungsschutzes
geradezu durchsetzt war und das zweite
scheiterte 2017 aus folgendem Grund habe
ich euch noch mal rausgesucht hört
selbst nach einstimmiger Auffassung des
Zweiten Senats verfolgt die NPD zwar
verfassungsfeindliche Ziele es fehlt
aber derzeit an konkret Anhaltspunkten
von Gewicht die es möglich erscheinen
lassen dass ihr Handeln zum Erfolg führt
ja das heißt nichts anderes als die NPD
war damals schon so klein und
unbedeutend geworden dass das nicht mehr
ausgereicht hat für ein Parteiverbot die
Richter sahen keine objektive
Gefährlichkeit mehr in der NPD und
zumindest dieses Argument würde heute
bei der AFD nicht greifen denn sie ist
alles andere als klein und unbedeutend
ich erinnere noch mal an die über 30% in
den Umfragen für den Osten und an ihre
letzten Wahlerfolge in Hessen und
[Applaus]
Bayern auch wenn ihr bis heute natürlich
jede regierungsoption fehlt welche
anderen Kriterien müssten also erfüllt
sein für ein erfolgreiches
Verbotsverfahren da fragen wir noch mal
die Juristin die AFD müsste sich von
ihrem Programm und Inhalt her gegen die
freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung
wenden und sie müsste auch darauf
ausgehen diese zu beseit
oder zu beeinträchtigen und das sind
sehr sehr hohe Hörden die Karlsruhe da
aufstellt gegen die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung mit aggressiv
kämpferischer Verhaltensweise heißt es
auch noch aber was genau bedeutet das
reicht es dass AFD Funktionäre sich
immer wieder offen islamfeindlich äußern
ausländerfeindlich äußern wir wollen
keine Einwanderung in die Sozialsysteme
und wir wollen keine Islamisierung liebe
Freunde burkers Kopftuchmädchen und
alimentierte messermänner und sonstige
tauge nichts werden unseren Wohlstand
das Wirtschaftswachstum und vor allem
den Sozialstaat nicht sicher oder
Homosexuellen feindlich ich will und
werde es nicht kampflos hinnehmen dass
unser Land zu einer regenbogenrepublik
umerzogen wird oder dass die AFD
ankündigt z.B den Rundfunkstaatsvertrag
sofort zu kündigen wenn sie an die Macht
käme was passiert denn wenn der höer
Ministerpräsident wird kündigt denn die
Medien Staatsverträge ja das macht der
hö ja
genau oder dass einzelne Mitglieder
immer wieder mit Hilfe von schiffren und
Codes ihre nationalsozialistische
Gesinnung zum Ausdruck bringen wie z.B
dieses Autokennzeichen hier das für
Adolf Hitler steht welche Kriterien
genau gemeint sind das hat die
Rechtssprechung leider nicht
ausbuchstabiert und das macht
Vorhersagen für den Ausgang eines
solchen Verfahrens auch so schwierig
aber sollte die AFD eines Tages wirklich
verboten werden dann würde sie sofort
aufgelöst alle abgeordn en der Partei in
Bundes und Landtagen würden ihr Mandat
verlieren und es wäre ihr auch verboten
Ersatzorganisationen zu gründen die AFD
Mitglieder und ihre Wähler die würden
damit aber natürlich nicht einfach
verschwinden was dann sehr
wahrscheinlich passieren würde
beschreibt die Juristin Schönenberger so
die AFD Würde aller Wahrscheinlichkeit
nach dieses Verbot in ihre große
Erzählung einweben von den illegitimen
Institutionen von der ihrer eigenen
Opferrolle von dem korrupten System ähm
das würde sich wunderbar einpassen schon
jetzt erzählt sie ja immer die
Geschichte dass sie illegitim bekämpft
wird und das Problem ist aber auch dass
die Wählerinnen und Wähler natürlich
aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach sich noch
weiter vom demokratischen System
entfernen würden wenn die Partei mit der
sie ihre Interessen irgendwie
wahrgenommen sehen dann verboten wird
schon der Versuch so ein
Verbotsverfahren in Gang zu setzen
könnte also voll nach hinten losgehen
gerade vor den drei Wahlen im Osten 2024
wo die AFD stärkste Kraft zu werden
droht noch mehr Menschen könnten sich
durch ein Verbotsverfahren von der
Demokratie abwenden fürchtet der
Politikwissenschaftler Albrecht von
Lucke der schreibt in der Süddeutschen
Zeitung es gibt tatsächlich eine
Situation in der eine Partei too big to
forbid ist also zu groß um verboten zu
werden ohne nicht gerade dadurch der
Demokratie zu schaden ihr erinnert euch
die NPD war am Ende zu klein um verboten
zu werden ist die AFD vielleicht schon
zu groß Marco wanderwitz der CDU-Mann
aus Sachsen wartet jedenfalls noch auf
ein wichtiges Urteil bevor er seinen
Verbotsantrag starten will Ende Februar
findet in Münster eine
Berufungsverhandlung vor
Oberverwaltungsgericht statt AFD gegen
den Bundesverfassungsschutz die Partei
hat gegen ihre Einstufung als
Verdachtsfall geklagt und solche
Einstufungen spielen in dieser
Geschichte eine ganz wichtige
[Musik]
Rolle die AFD wird mittlerweile in drei
Bundesländern vom Verfassungsschutz als
gesichert rechtsextremistisch eingestuft
in Thüringen schon seit März 2021 in
SachsenAnhalt seit November diesen
Jahres und in Sachsen ganz frisch seit
Dezember die Gesamtpartei wird als
Verdachtsfall behandelt das ist
sozusagen die Vorstufe zur richtigen
Beobachtung als Begründung für die
Einstufung dient den
Verfassungsschützern vor allem der
völkischnationalistische Ansatz in der
Migrationsfrage der sich immer wieder in
Äußerungen von AFD Führungspersonal
findet ein Beispiel dafür der
thüringische afdchef höcke den man ja
auch offiziell als Faschist bezeichnen
darf der warnt in seinem Buch vor dem
Volkstod durch den Bevölkerungsaustausch
es brauche ein großangelegtes
remigrationsprojekt das heißt nichts
anderes als dass höcke Millionen Bürger
aus dem Land verbannen will und das
funktioniert laut höcke nur mit einer
Zitat wohltemperierten Grausamkeit was
diese Einstufung als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch für die drei AFD
ostlandesverbände in der Praxis bedeutet
erklärt uns der Politikwissenschaftler
Vorländer von der TU Dresden ja der
Verfassungsschutz kann jetzt
nachrichtendienstliche Mittel einsetzen
er könnte also beispielsweise faulute
einschleusen und sich dadurch über die
innere Struktur aber auch die
Kommunikation das Handeln der Akteure
ein klareres Bild verschaffen sass er
Indizien zusammentragen kann die
vielleicht dazu führen dass es zu einem
Verbotsverfahren der AFD kommt könnte
also sein dass diese Beobachtung dafür
sorgt dass der AFD Führungszirkel doch
ein bisschen Muffensausen bekommt und
sich mäßigt könnte sein dass das Label
recht extrem manchen potentiellen
afdwähler noch mal umdenken lässt ich
glaube die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht
besonders groß denn in Thüringen
erinnert euch wird die AFD schon seit
zwei Jahren offiziell als
rechtsextremistische Bestrebung
behandelt und hat das bisher Wähler dort
irgendwie abgeschreckt nein im Gegenteil
der Zuspruch steigt der oberste
Verfassungsschützer sieht hier eine
Aufgabe für uns alle nicht allein der
Verfassungsschutz ist dafür zuständig
die umfrageerte der AFD zu senken das
dazu haben wir wir keinerlei
Möglichkeiten aber wir können die
Bevölkerung wachrütteln wir können
Politiker wachrütteln und ja der Kampf
für unsere Demokratie muss in die
Gesamtgesellschaft geführt werden und
genau solche Appelle sind es die die AFD
so richtig auf den Baum bringen der
Verfassungsschutz geriert sich hier zu
einem Verfassungsfeind
warum weil die AFD durch den Einsatz des
Verfassungsschutzes
im politischen Parteienwettbewerb
strukturell benachteiligt wird indem
diese Partei indem wir diskriminiert
werden was heißt das jetzt für mich
heißt das zusammenfassend wenn wenn so
ein Verbotsverfahren überhaupt kommt
dann wäre es erstens stand heute sehr
wahrscheinlich aussichtslos zweitens
langwierig sowas kann sich
erfahrungsgemäß über Jahre hinziehen und
es hätte somit drittens keinerlei Effekt
für die ostwahlen im nächsten Jahr und
selbst wenn es Jurist möglich ist muss
man sich fragen ob es auch politisch
klug wäre denn ein Verbotsverfahren
könnte eben auch genau das Gegenteil
erreichen nämlich das AFD Wähler sagen
jetzt erst recht sehr wahrscheinlich
muss die Auseinandersetzung mit der AFD
also weiter politisch erfolgen den
anderen Parteien muss schon ein bisschen
mehr einfallen als ein Verbot um den
Rechtsruck im Land und die
Politikverdrossenheit zu bekämpfen oder
was denkt ihr lasst es uns wissen in den
Kommentaren und schaut auch gerne unsere
anderen Videos von Inside politics